thank you
stealing from Star Wars ignoring the
WASP modug but fans are seriously
frustrated with Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania
the first big issue fans took with
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum Mania is a
lack of quantum realm rules the entire
premise of the quantum realm is that it
is an unknown location seemingly ruled
by chaos however the film tries to
reflect this by letting a bunch of
inexplicable things happen and not
giving the audience any source of
explanation for the events while the few
things were explained like how the Ooze
that the characters understand every
language if consumed that just left the
other aspects of the quantum Journey
that were not even touched on even more
confusing for example how could humans
breathe there in a subatomic atmosphere
it makes sense that the creature to live
down there have adapter to their
surroundings but when Scott and Company
head to the quantum realm they can all
breathe the air without their suits one
fan on Twitter even questioned how
breathing was even possible if the
quantum realm is smaller than air
molecules this isn't exactly ant science
is it one of the biggest gags of the
film is the introduction of Modoc The
Man Behind modug turns out to be a facer
Ant-Man fans will recognize from the
franchise Darren played by Corey Stahl
making Darren the person inside the
mechanism is a decent enough idea
especially since Marvel films love to
bring back familiar faces however the
character ultimately ends up being a
little more than a big joke and not much
of a threat at all what's more the CGI
for Modoc is incredibly bad to the point
of being distracting one fan on Twitter
said there's lots of questionable CGI in
this one modak in particular looked
atrocious though the character is
definitely supposed to be hard to look
at there is no scenario in which he is
supposed to be this ridiculous the
character's visual representation makes
it impossible to view him as a threat
too even more so because of the random
unnecessary nude shot the audience is
surprised by when he has fastened into
his Machinery one fan asked what did I
do to deserve seeing Modoc but naked
modok is good for a few laughs but is
otherwise mostly a frustrating and
forgettable character because of the
poor CGI and the unnecessary nudity it's
a hole so deep it cannot be filled
when Scott and his cohorts are poured
into the quantum realm they immediately
get separated this leaves Scott and
Cassie searching for Hank Janice and
hope having spent 30 years in the
quantum realm Janet knows the most out
of all of them and is their best bet to
navigate their way through the chaotic
environment Janet leads Hank in hopes
for virus source and fans of the Star
Wars franchise may feel familiar with
this setting especially because of its
distinct similarities the Moz Eisley
Cantina in Star Wars a new home in
Ant-Man and the WASP quanta Mania
creatures of all kinds are seen drinking
together at the bar just like in a new
hope this led some fans to believe that
the bar scene was further proof that
quantumania was trying a little too hard
to be like Star Wars one Twitter user
was upset about the similarities and
tweeted why was quantumania just a weird
Star Wars rip-off MCU baby what is you
doing another Twitter user noticed some
similarities with another popular MCU
film writing Quantum realm is basically
Star Wars times Guardians of the Galaxy
though the creatures are not the same
and there are certainly some unique
elements the energize music and overall
setting were too similar to the famous
Cantina scene for many viewers
one consistent theme throughout all of
the Ant-Man films as Scott's love for
his daughter Cassie their relationship
is Scott's motivation for everything he
does in his life and Scott does not
hesitate to put himself In Harm's Way if
it means ensuring Cassie's safety this
is no different than Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum Mania when Cassie and Scott
are captured by Kang Scott is asked to
use the pimp articles to fix the energy
source for Kang's ship so he can escape
the quantum realm however Scott refuses
to do this because he does not want to
help Kang and act against Janet's
instructions gang tries to torture Scott
to get him to change his mind but he
does not budge his opinion quickly
changes though when Kang begins to
torture Cassie and threatens to kill her
Kang torturing Cassie though not totally
unexpected is a low blow nothing in the
world is more important to Scott than
Cassie which is made clear by the scene
where all of the Scott possibilities are
working together to acquire the energy
source only in an effort to save Cassie
a fan wrote on Twitter the for Cassie
scene with Scott's probability variants
forming an ant hill have been bowling
fans agree that Scott's love for Cassie
is the best part of the Ant-Man series
making the fact that he has to watch her
in pain all the more upsetting
perhaps the most frustrating part of
that man in the WASP Quantum Mania is
the anti-climactic third act which
finally showcases Kang's power
throughout the film Kangas portrays this
ominously powerful being he can kill on
command and a seemingly unlimited
strength that comes from his helmet and
suit beyond that he does not hesitate to
show this power off when he wants to get
his way it makes sense that when Kang
fights Scott the two are evenly matched
after all Kang suit is damaged and
Scott's suit is still intact however
before Kang suit is broken it is
ultimately the ants and mo darker that
take him down which seems a bit silly
the ants were pretty Advanced as hunk
explains but it doesn't really seem like
that even combined with modok's sneak
attack will be even remotely enough to
beat the man who has killed several
Avengers the way that Kangas ultimately
defeated ends up feeling more like a cop
house than a well-deserved victory at
the end of the film Janet is able to
open the portal to get everyone home but
they have to move quickly Hank and Janet
jumped through followed by hope however
Scott pushes Cassie through but stays
back to keep Kang from getting out
leading to an intense battle when it
seems like all hope is lost for Scott
making it back hope crashes through the
portal at the last second and helps
Scott take down Kang however the portal
closes and Scott and hope are left in
the quantum realm for all of two seconds
until Cassie reopens the portal allowing
kope and Scott to escape the situation
seems incredibly anti-climactic with no
Stakes or Consequences that have any
impact on the characters they defeat
Kang but instead of getting stuck there
giving Cassie and her grandparents a
chance to try and get them out over time
they are immediately able to make it
home one fan tweeted the movie would
have felt more consequential if hope
Scott was stuck in the quantum realm it
makes sense how Cassie was able to
quickly open the portal but the pacing
felt off even a brief scene of Cassie
panicking and trying to reconnect the
device would have added some needed
drama to the situation for many fans to
have hope and Scott's sacrifice mean
virtually nothing until they are saved
immediately is frustrating and
narratively unsatisfied fine easy peasy
one of the biggest criticisms comes from
the film's lack of Hope content there is
a lot of roommate for Paul Rhodes Scott
Lang to tap into the plus and his
emotional depth while Jonathan Majors
Kang the Conqueror steals the show
Michelle Pfeiffer dives into her role as
Janus as she guides her family through
the quantum realm however hope played by
actress Evangeline Lilly is shoved to
the side in favor of these other
characters fans found this pretty
disappointing especially since the film
is supposed to be Ant-Man and the WASP
not just Ant-Man one fan on Twitter said
it best Evangeline Lily is wasp in
quantumania felt non-existent or maybe I
can articulate it by saying she was
there physically yet her presence wasn't
felt another fun theorized on Twitter
that Lily might have been shoved to the
sidelines because of her vaccination
views which she publicly talked about
during the coronavirus pandemic however
as the same user points out Leticia
writes who took the lead in Black
Panther wakanda forever has similar
views and is in nearly every scene of
her film no matter what the reason it is
clear that the WASP is much less of a
priority in this film and seemingly in
the MCU in general Lilly has a lot of
talent and brings a lot to the scenes
she is in but she is not in as nearly as
many as she should be for it to be
considered an Ant-Man and the WASP film
though this is not a specific moment
from the film we would be remiss if we
did not mention how upset fans were upon
the recasting of Cassie everyone knew
young Cassie from the first couple of
films would be recast because of the
blip but Catherine Newsome was not
supposed to be Cassie the role was
supposed to be played by Emma Furman a
young actress who played Cassie for a
brief scene in Avengers end game her
emotional depth and resemblance to Road
Scott Lang were ever done from just a
short scene with the two of them so why
did Newton play Cassie when Furman was
cast Cassie's role was just a small bit
part for one film now that Cassie has
been given a more important role in the
MCU the casting team at Marvel opted for
someone with more experience and more
recognizable name unfortunately Furman
was not told of this change directly and
many fans weren't happy in a Twitter
post one fun wrote Emma Furman Cassie's
actress from endgame was robbed of the
chance of a lifetime and found out about
it the exact same way wheel did through
the announcement on social media they
didn't even tell her the way it was
handled is devastating and leaves fans
wondering if Furman would have been the
better choice for the role
[Music]